we have a voicemail number two one nine
two david p you can call any time of day
of my story yesterday about protesting
and civil disobedience and general
strikes created a flurry a deluge of
feedback here is one voicemail about
that issue take a listen hi David my
name is Nate I just watched your video
on civil disobedience and that now is
the time and you wanted to hear from us
and I think that what we are going to
need to see to get the kind of traction
that we use is individuals who are able
to do more high-profile protests things
like for example Gandhi comes to mind
with hunger strike now I'm not
suggesting that we have the same kind of
problem that they had in India and the
time no it's high-profile protests which
only more wealthy and more privileged
individuals can do and are in a position
to do is that it that's okay because
they're alright I tend to agree with the
idea that having some high-profile
protesters would make a difference but
at the same time even when moderately
high-profile people I get themselves
arrested because they are you know
assembled and the way you're not
supposed to or trespass you know how
they get digging or there's a bunch of
ways you can arrest protesters and then
it's kind of like a catch-and-release
type of thing it doesn't make that big
of news like I still think it makes
bigger news when five hundred thousand
people gathered a protest in New York
City then when one prominent person gets
arrested protesting or something like
that I don't know if like individuals
protesting is the way forward unless
they are like top top like a list people
yeah and I feel like most of those a
list people are not willing to do that
sort of thing especially if they're like
an actor or an athlete because then
you're alienating half of your fan base
who may support Trump may not have the
same politics as you so it's too risky
for them that's why I respect the
athletes that come forward and say like
LeBron James for example who has been
increasingly talking politics by the way
I agree
most of most everything that he's been
saying I respect that because he says I
don't care what the impact is in terms
of people being fans of mine but at the
same time it's very easy for him not to
care because he's already made enough
money right it won't really affect his
livelihood if he loses half his fan base
at this point there's not going to yeah
and maybe for him I feel like most of
his fan base is already left leaning
anyway I mean young basketball fans
that's my two cents on it anyway if
you're dealing with an older actor yeah
you know some guy like George Clooney
who is liberal but I'm sure he appeals
to a lot of people all sides of the
political spectrum I think it's a little
bit more damaging to him and his brand
although again he's made enough money
already and he's set for life so that
that certainly reduces the risk yeah I
think that we definitely need more
prominent protests that's for sure the
exact form and circumstances I think we
can sort of have a conversation about on
the bonus show today we will talk about
PayPal ending their business
relationship with Alex Jones as Infowars
we will talk about a Japanese spacecraft
throwing two small Rovers at an asteroid
it's happening and we will talk about
Congress considering requiring more
legroom on planes all of those stories
and more on today's bonus show become a
member at WWJ ENCOM that will give you
instant access you can also get access
to the bonus show by making a $5 a month
or more pledge on patreon at patreon.com
slash david pakman show